Metaphysical store
reality.
How it seems to have happened to us is that over the last five years,
something like that,
we invented a new way of looking at the world as a materialist
and that is exactly the view of story.
It's different than that.
It's a new technology and the problem seems to be that the emergence of that
which has made us wealthy,
technologically powerful.
There's a,
he said,
boy,
fundamental way metaphysics of our basic story
need to have this idea in the lady 1900 leaving that the conflict between the
scientists worldview and the religious world view,
a designated religious will view
that.
He described that as the debit card and he believed that because that had
happened,
we had lost our moorings or ethical moorings and that our society is going to
wash away for that between nihilism and totalitarianism.
That's a con and neat.
You died quite young,
believed that in order to recover from that and find our marriage,
that we were going to have to replace the gods that we once believed in,
let's say,
or your God,
but we want to plead it with some notion of our own divinity.
Take responsibility for creating our own doubters.
That was his idea is superman,
the Overman now yo was very interested in niches,
diagnosis because he knew that we lived inside stories and the stories had
certain accidents of value and then our faith and our fundamental story had been
shaken not least by our scientific,
the rising of scientific knowledge,
and he was interested in trying to figure out how people might find themselves
reoriented so they didn't turn to nihilism,
let's say,
or two to telecare.
Ian Utopian world news bucket put themselves back in the story,
but he didn't buy the niches prognosis for cure because yoga was influenced by
Freud and Freud.
You out that
people didn't create their own values.
You can't do that because you have to nature you and the nature manifests itself
within you regardless of your choice.
There's things that you can't get yourself to do and know that,
right?
Because it was a matter of creating your own values.
You just think,
well you can wake up one morning and you could just tell yourself what to do.
Like go to the gym three times a week so that you know you're in good shape.
Stop eating junk or quit drinking and bang just cause you've got control over
yourself and well obviously that's just not the case and that's because there
are all sorts of things operating inside of you that have their own autonomy.
They're all own nature that you Glen,
he will have to contend with it.
So that's why you went back inside the human psyche,
so to speak,
to look at the fantasies that we spontaneously generated,
disagree with of the world,
to see if he can find out what the pattern constituted.
Perfect.
Now I'm going to tell you this little story.
So this is the idea.
This is partly,
he's stories are parked of your ride from thousands or even can have tens of
thousands of years of watching how people act it successfully and unsuccessfully
in the world and extracting patterns.
So the patterns get extracted,
they get more abstract and they get less real in some sense,
but they get more broadly applicable.
So let me tell you first story.
So this is from the opening chapter opening parts of geography.
So there's an idea in genesis,
this is roughly how the idea is laid out and it's an idea that is expressed in
consultancy all over the world in different forms.
So the first time you had is that there's sorts of two domains,
major fee,
there's potential chaos and there's order having more.
Okay.
Now that's,
that's the,
that's the structure of reality.
It's like the Dow was getting yet that's the same thing that you're hemispheres
are matching order and chaos and that's what the world's made up.
Okay.
I'm,
there's a third factor.
And the third factor is the thing that immediately if we noticed too,
and that would be,
that's equivalent.
I think one,
one are people mean when they talk about consciousness because that seems to be
what consciousness,
dubs,
consciousness establishes order your conscious,
you make decisions,
you make it a world.
But while you're being conscious in attempting,
you're attending what you don't yet understand and haven't asked her.
So you face with something going and potential and you transform that
effortfully in carefully to what you understand and what you couldn't have that.
So that's what your consciousness does.
And the Genesis you see that portrayed,
you sees death portrayed as something that's defined because if dividing spirit,
so that's basically Gallois y'all was y'all was,
what would you call it?
The process by which you all,
what generates the world is being turned her.
This is the Christianization of that story is the term of the logos and the
logos is the capacity for attentive,
communicative,
truthful speech.
And so there's a deep idea at the beginning of genesis step
whenever defining consciousness is that which uses truthful,
communicated speech to encounter the chaos of the unknown and to transform it
and to have that border.
And so that's a technical description of the structure of reality and it's an
ethical injunction as well because what happens in the opening chapters of
genesis is that God use the logos to create the world out of that preexisted
chaos and he,
and when he does that in stages,
he pronounces it good.
And so there's an idea there [inaudible] idea
because one of the things he might ask yourself,
and this is one of the things that the mass murderers asking themselves all the
time is being justified or is it something against which you should strive and
destroy?
And that's a very good question because life is very,
very difficult and it's full of suffering and it's full of new trail and it's
full of malevolence and it's not an unreasonable proposition.
He questioned whether it would be better if you're not thinking of all the
assistants and the people who take the steps to doing the terrible things that
they ended up doing.
Answer that question in the affirmative.
They believe that life itself is so unbearable in its fundamental structure that
normally should it not exist,
but that the right response to it is to take revenge against the fact that its
existence.
And that's part of the answer to how you get to where you have to go if you're
going to render down and drive it for camp blocks on the city,
on city sidewalks,
it's a deep,
deep bro and it's justifiable,
but the hypothesis it's laid out in genesis,
which is an amazing hypothesis,
is that despite the fragility of the world and the vulnerability of the world,
and it's called cleverly,
let's say towards malevolence,
if you encountered with consciousness and counters the potential that the world
is extracted from and he does that truthfully,
then what is created as a consequence is good.
And I would say that's the host.
That's the most fundamental act of faith and I think that's the fundamental
ethical question that lives,
it's that underlies the entire corpus of the stories in which our culture and
all of them are paid.
The question is,
are you willing to act out the proposition that being is good?
If you abide by the truth,
and what's interesting is that it's an existential question,
Nate.
It's not a question that you can that can be answered by fact because no one can
prove it to you because they can't.
They can't tell you what your life is going to be like if you do that because
you're the only person that can find out.
And the only way you can find out is essentially by risking everything you can
decide,
well,
I'm going to separately proposition that truthful being is that being that
producers what's good,
and then I'm going to abide by that.
But then the springs things will how to you,
because it isn't necessarily the case that if you attempt to abide by your own
truth,
that everything that happens to every second is going to be demonstrative proof
that that's the right pathway.
You're gonna get yourself in all sorts of trouble.
If you do that,
you know that perfectly well because there's uncomfortable conversations that
you should probably have heard a few people.
And if you have those uncomfortable conversations,
it's not like there's big,
it's just going to be roses and sunshine.
While you're having the discussion.
Quite the contrary.
The truth is a very disruptive force,
especially people that are living inside an illusion.
And so it is,
it's a statement.
It's an,
if it's a metaphysical statement of faith.